I think I forgot what it was but the
other day I had to tell my mom about
like what she was saying I think I
actually had I had this conversation
with her maybe not recently but I had to
tell her that something that jizz to her
the other day but well so what happened
with the Obama what kind of hair braided
scheme is this so let's go back to the
air branding thing
[Music]
article submitted by Joseph does anybody
call you Joseph some people do people of
my past people who don't know he
submitted the article no what if we
start calling you Joe mama again you can
I'm I get called different names what do
you prefer Joe Papa Joe Biden Joe Biden
yeah you like that are you sleepy Joe
especially when they put a [__] before
it Joe Obama speaking of Joe Obama yeah
submitted by Joseph we're going to be
talking about Malik Obama Mr Barack
Obama's transition brother you like that
you got a brother yeah he's got a little
hater
you don't pay attention no I don't
honestly I don't if I'm being honest you
just said hey man yeah yeah I'll pay
attention I'm sorry dude we'll add We'll
add Lawrence a couple days ago I um
that's hostile I look on trending on
Twitter it's called X by the way yeah X
what is it it's called You Have To Call
It by X now you can't say yeah you go
the the app formerly known as Twitter
you ever just go on the trending section
and then I saw Malik Obama so I was like
oh who's this and I clicked it and it's
his brother
carry on you're probably gonna talk [__]
you're probably gonna show us what what
happened no good where's his real
brother that's exactly I didn't even
know he had a brother I didn't either
yeah yeah no it's his real brother by
the same father I believe it might be a
different mother oh okay same last name
that's why the skin tone difference yeah
yes the skin tone difference there's a
discrepancy here let me uh let me show
the discrepancy and skin tone difference
people don't think it's real his
brother's dark chocolate and Obama's
Hershey's milk chocolate insane I think
the Hat's really impressive though
oh got it okay and it says does it call
him light skin
yes or maybe it's missing a letter and
it's supposed to say like foreign
[Laughter]
I've been seeing a lot of let's go
Brandon signs it just says forbidden
Kingdom
yeah yeah he's pretty mean yeah he he
hates he hates uh Barack the Trump fans
are very rabid though aren't they
they're very like rapid they're very
extreme dude the comments on his [__]
were like he's talking crap to um Obama
pretty funny people are like can you
just please send your brother 900
already
like
it looks like yeah
basically uh this self-proclaimed proud
Republican uh wearing the four Biden
on August 13th uh wrote on the app
formerly known as Twitter me and fake
ass a snake AKA why does he keep putting
an a after ass by the way it's really
weird I don't know he does it more than
once what does he do he puts a what so
he says like fake ass snake but he puts
an A in between s and snake fake ass uh
snake fake ass a snake I'm just trying
to do it yeah you fake ass a snake yeah
that's kind of cool when you do it
though you fake ass a snake yeah
fake ass a snake that's what he meant
yeah
that's a snake that's got to be you
gotta put the Sass in there because
there's two s's yes when you're
passionate and you're you're typing away
dude sometimes you forget letters yeah
that's true multiple times only that
part he's doing it in a snake voice
thick as the snakes oh like that yeah
yeah
yeah that's Harry Potter bro so me and
fake as the snake president when he was
a nobody why do I keep talking like yeah
he throws a throwback photo of them uh
in Kenyan Garb uh and he also comments
the next day before he became a snob
snob in all caps by the way oh [__] so
this is basically going around on uh on
I guess I'm still gonna call him tweets
uh on the twitters and he said I just
wanted to be fake as a snake's big
brother but he rejected me he is fake as
a stick oh no it actually says fake as a
snake uh without the ass
so he told you he can't spell yeah he's
In the Heat of the Moment bro he's
typing away he is fake as a snake and is
a traitor and he has his soul to the
devil he sold his soul to the devil so
that's basically how uh
upset he is this is the photo reference
of the Kenyan Garb before he was uh
elected an official or a president
load
they need to make a movie about like
their childhood and why they like resent
each other you know what happened what
were the things the issues it's probably
gonna be very similar to La Bamba
Obama
who's that guy in the back though
even darker third brother
they'll make a the sequel to that damn
what do you think went wrong in the
Obama family then or do you think the
brother did they actually grow up as a
family together like very close because
he's only a half right does he know
Obama from Hawaii Dude does he live in
Hawaii
so that's probably what it is long
distance
like just being on a nice Island yeah
dude someone else included yeah he's
Wade he's throwing up shakas all day
poor this guy is just on the internet
just ranting yeah somebody had concluded
that the rift between them was a
byproduct of jealousy
um Barack Obama sought out his family
after losing his father he found love
but uh it became a tangled web they were
each other's best men apparently they
were each other's best men see Perfect
movie yeah damn sometimes people do that
by default though yeah but but this
person speculates that he expected too
much of his brother perhaps he was lent
money for some hair braid scheme a blah
blah blah hair braid scheme Wait Wait
Don't blah blah blah that dude let's go
back to that yeah hair breaker it's
definitely hair braiding hair braiding
hair braided scheme yeah I think the
idea is that when he became president
maybe this guy wanted to um kind of like
fall be vice president yeah he also he
also apparently ran for a government
position in Kenya I think
um and the uh the campaign slogan was
like Obama over there Obama over here or
something
dude he's writing coattails so
so
[Laughter]
it's pretty good actually how did he not
win right that's crazy I see a dance
going along with that you should be a
campaign manager bro I think you have a
talent you have a hidden talent maybe I
don't know maybe you saw something
covering it right now yeah it's kind of
on the spot slogan for that right but he
didn't win see because he didn't make it
into a song he should have used uh to
the window to the wall yeah
Obama to the window Obama
[Laughter]
what does that mean the sweatshirts
they're like but don't say the last part
okay don't say the last one oh man like
that's our favorite part it's a PR
problem you gotta try you gotta change
it to treat treat treat treat we give
you three three three three three
they say
oh skate skates yeah you know my mom
growing up she loved that song so she
would always say the ski part yeah yeah
it was a ringtone for a while she didn't
know that it meant what she's hey she's
wow one bro but she didn't know it was
come childish you know I don't think she
knows to this day maybe I should tell
her tell her tell her she definitely
knows don't tell her ma you're talking
about ejaculate okay don't don't tell
her but just like Play the song around
her and see if she like starts humming
it and stuff I think I forgot what it
was but the other day I had to tell my
mom about like what she was saying I
think I actually did I had this
conversation with her maybe not recently
but I had to tell her that something
meant jizz to her the other day but well
so what happened with the Obamas what
kind of hair braided scheme is this so
let's go back to the air braiding thing
what other things could have meant geez
besides skeet and jizz just give me give
me like three more videos and I'll think
of it was it a song it was a song
because my mom likes to say things like
from what's another uh jizz synonym
well maybe it is in context like like
bust oh yeah okay okay uh nut or like
we'll think of it well maybe not yeah no
was it nut or cream cream no it wasn't
cream dude that's crazy yeah that's
obvious my mom's not an idiot dude what
the [__] my mom knows come when she
hears it knows come euphemisms okay
Jesus Christ
uh that's like style dude this guy
that's like Anthony Lee I don't know I'm
just trying to throw anything let's go
back to air braiding please okay
did you look into why they like he hates
his brother so much it's just it's just
speculation but it really does seem to
he wrote a book and all that dude this
is what happened everyone's making up
their own [__] theories he probably
did write a book he's trying to like
make money off of the fame and stuff huh
so it says so weird how Malik Obama
turned on Barack Obama like this only
because he didn't seem to think Barack
was a snake when he used his name to
boost a failed campaign for local
government in Kenya Obama here Obama
there was a slogan ended up with less
than 3K votes such a good thing such a
good slogan but is that not his name too
well I think here Obama there is
definitely using his name too right
actually yeah he said he he was the
first Obama because people were arguing
I was reading his tweet he fights with
people in the comments it's so funny
because he's older he's like yeah he's
like I was first I'm Obama first so
that's his [__] claim to fame is like
okay apparently I'm a famous brother
apparently I want to say that always
always for safety but he does mention
things like when Rock did take office he
wouldn't like return his phone calls as
much it would be really hard to contact
him he's a [__] president yeah he's a
little little busy yeah but that's his
brother okay he should pick up the phone
for his [__] brother you do have
priorities okay what if his pet bunny
died and then he needs to tell Barack so
they could talk about it and it's like
oh so you're a [__] president now and
now you you're too busy to talk to your
own brother yeah that's sneaky Behavior
right yeah it's very snake snake ass
Bugs Bunny was my [__] favorite one
out of the pack and it's like all right
I see how it is looks funny and I want a
presidential funeral for him yeah that's
what he was asking for and he probably
comes over a weird-ass guy man he sounds
weird yeah he probably killed the bunny
first though before he called
brother that you have to apologize for
like sorry my brother's Lee tidied if
that's his main argument like my I was
Obama first that's crazy
that's the best censorship I've ever
heard they're ever gonna resolve these
issues no
OK like as people get older you know
things become like a little less like
you know like that's very mature and
optimistic I think it's dependent on uh
Malik big brother yeah big big brother
kind of tells himself like yo I was
tripping dude sorry I think that would
be cool when he becomes like a famous
rapper though first oh he has to get
gain some Fame and then be like ah yeah
Malik does sound cool for a rapper name
yeah you know what it looks a cool name
you know what does suck though because
if if he does come out and talk about
[__] it's not
um people aren't gonna believe him
because he's too crazy yeah yeah so if
he like if he is airing all this stuff
out it's like some of it might be true
but we will never know because he's like
crazy
yeah he's crazy yeah I saw a post I said
it's a good rap name but it's a good rap
name yeah Malik's a good rap name Malik
Obama dude Malik Obama's a strong name
dude it is strong I feel like he could
do he can move mountains with that name
yeah but he's gotta stop saying I was
the first Obama because that's not a
good look but it's like I was the first
Obama
then we're cooking with fire yeah now
it's fresh yeah I saw him posting a
picture of
uh Barack Obama and then he says my
brother is gay
exactly is that where the uh is that
where the rumors came from I heard about
that I heard about rumors of Obama being
gay yeah this dude confirmed him why is
that so funny it is really funny you
don't expect that no it's funny because
it's so petty it's like stupid brother
funny because that's what Dave Chappelle
did to Martin Lawrence and Blue Streak
if you remember that what can you tell
me about Logan I tell you that he's gay
foreign